Pandora is home to many creatures  including acrons or as humans might know  them banshees inhabiting his Navi Avatar  Jake befriends nichiri who teaches him  the way of Pandora culture natiri shares  with Jake that the bond between a navi  and KRON is very powerful the crons  choose the navi and it's important to  decipher which creature has chosen you  as its companion Jake quickly matches  within Akron despite having very little  training and takes a breathtaking flight  under the continued direction of nitiri  Jake Masters the art of the crown riding  offering up some of the film's most  thrilling Airborne scenes I may not be  much of a horse guy but I was born to do  this